vuelven los aviones del aeropuerto de
kabul la aerolínea afgana ariana hizo
varios trayectos entre tres capitales de
provincia del país los primeros desde
que los talibanes tomaron el control
esto fue nuestro primer vuelo ayer
fuimos a herat y pasamos la noche ahí
luego subimos a los pasajeros y volamos
a kandahar y en kandahar viajamos a
kabul y acabamos de llegar
si dios quiere los vuelos se retoman y
tendremos dos más a herat y kandahar
tras la retirada de eeuu las pistas
habían quedado inutilizadas y llenas de
material abandonado
además los talibanes no tenían la
capacidad técnica de operar las
instalaciones
sin embargo qatar envió un equipo para
reanudar las operaciones algo que ha
permitido que kabul también pueda
recibir ayuda humanitaria
el aeropuerto de la capital afgana se ha
convertido en un punto estratégico
desde un punto de vista logístico
permite la llegada de suministros para
una población que los necesita con
urgencia y además permite el
desplazamiento interno en una geografía
extremadamente montañosa pero desde un
punto de vista político también es clave
hacer funcionar el aeropuerto permite a
los talibanes proyectar una imagen de
regreso a la normalidad y de estabilidad
que han predicado durante las tres
semanas que llevan en el poder
además de dar un paso hacia retomar los
vuelos internacionales algo
indispensable para que los civiles que
lo desean puedan abandonar afganistán
una de las exigencias más firmes de las
potencias occidentales al futuro
gobierno talibán